*mark screaming* oohhOOHH AHHHH IT'S ON ME HE'S GONNA KILL ME OHGOD
Hello everybody my name is
Markiplier and welcome back to
Subnautica! And, also, welcome back to the
WALL of NAMES! Yeah, I finally got the
materials necessary to build the lockers
again and I've already *Mark stutters* PICKED
I'VE PIACKED - PIA!
I have PICKED out four comments from
the comments section, and the first one
is red icorn who said "if you beat the
sea Emperor you win the game," and I'm not
entirely sure that's true, considering
the Sea Emporer isn't in the game, but the sea
dragon leviathan is, and the sea dragon
leviathan resides in the inactive lava (never wanna see him again)
zone. And then there's Ben Gosper who
said "Tip number 2 don't ever, EVER
forget that there are Reaper Leviathans," (PLEASE don't)
and I don't know how I could, because I'm
about to venture around the back end of
the Aurora, and I'm pretty sure when I go
over there, Imma have a whole bunch
of leviathans in my face (good for you), and I don't
have the batteries necessary to be able
to deviate the path around them so I'm
just hoping I'm gonna get lucky and they
don't spot me and gobble me up. But, you (bet they will)
know, anything could happen here around
the Aurora! Then there's Lemon Queen who
said 'Hey Markle sparkle you haven't
forgotten your children, right? i'm sure
you remember their names, obviously.'" And
yes, I do:
it's Jeffrey, Billy, Samwise and Marshall
and no, I didn't look that up before the
start of the episode! Stop doubting me! I
know what I'm doing (SURE YOU DO MARK) and then there's
jokes 4*random babbling* jokes for days who said "I
eagerly await the return of Bubblebutt."
Which is what I'm gonna name my sea moth,
because that was my favorite
favorite name. Besides obviously Fuck a Duck
was a good name but i'll rename
My,  uh, my big ol' submaruuner Fuck a Duck
instead of Fuck the Ocean
I don't know. I'll figure it out as time goes on. ¯\_(ツ)_/¯
Anyway, this is just about grown. Uh, it's only
got 8% left, but it's not
quite there. So what I'm gonna do-
*very confused* What did I put in this?(nuthin)
I didn't put anything that luggage bag!
There's nothing in there- so what I got
in here is, I got some copper so I actually DO
have the stuff necessary to be able to
more batteries I believe
Shit
Shiiat! Ah shiiat. I need to go get acid
mushrooms.
Oh no... Please tell me that's sunRISE and
not sunSET because one of those is my favorite (Fun Fact, favourite is sunRISE)
thing and one of those is the absolute
worst thing in the world. *Stutters* Eventually
i'll need to fi- Ah,
fuck man! I seem to be going through- Oh
God sun is setting. *chuckling* Well this is gonna
be a dark episode! Good thing I'm gonna
get enough batteries to be able to
navigate the dark with my sea glider.
But I don't know if I'm gonna be able to
do that well and survive, so I'm gonna
make up some batteries. And eventually what
I'll need to do is I'll need to make
these- the, uh, battery charger again because
I can't constantly keep making these
batteries over and over again. It's a
waste of resources, when I can recharge
them, but I just don't have the capacity
to do that. But now we're getting into
the extremely new territory in this game
because there's a lot of new stuff and
there's a lot of new setup to get new
stuff. I've been told there are new sections
in the Aurora. I don't know where they
are. If they're in the same hole in the
wall that will get me there, that's where
I'm gonna go first, just because that's what
I'm familiar with. But also I've been
told there's stuff around the backside of
the Aurora where it used to just be empty
ocean. Now I don't know what else there
COULD be in there and I'm just going to
stuff everything in "Lemon Queen" here -
even though that sounds really weird - but,
either way, I'm gonna put away what I
don't need, and I don't think I need
titanium on the way out there, so I... am
going to put overflow in "Jokes for Days" (Ain't that PUN/JOKEnificent...okay im sorry)
I don't need the- maybe I DO need the
fire extinguisher, because if I go on the
Aurora, I might actually need that, so I'm
gonna swap batteries here- Oh no, I-I'm
actually pretty good here.
Okay so- Oooh! Fuck you, man!
Jesus! I think I scared him more than he
scared me. But he still scared me
enough to fill my pants with poop and
pee! Ugh, cut that out me. I-I'm already
on the backside of the Aurora.
Ah!  Fucking fucking fuck, STOP!
Why did you bite my butthole, you bitch?!
*raging* You butthole bitin' bitch! Fuck you!
Anyway, that's not why I'm here. Let me
just see if I can get any rare minerals out of
this...
Uh, nope, just titanium. Okay, so I guess
change of plans: we're gonna go straight
around the backside of the Aurora-
*Growling noises* AAAAH! .. Okay, so
hopefully- I need that quartz! Gimme that quartz-
we're gonna be okay
what are you doing here- AAH! *Gasp* OOOOOOO
that was a mistake! Aaaah! Alright, we- we dove into
a place I didn't want to dive into
because I didn't realize we were
here just yet. Oh good a power cell! That's
actually kind of nice! (imagine that)
Okay, at least I won't have to make those. I'll
probably need that first-aid kit because
I'm gonna get bitten in the asshole (like he just did)
a bunch (Karen: Warning, 30 seconds of oxygen remaining)
I got it, Karen, thanks for looking out for
me! Oo boy, we got some rumblies down here!
Good thing when the engines exploded, it
dumped all the power cells directly
below the engines. (ain't that useful)
Oh god. That doesn't look safe. Well, this
looks like a dead end.
Okay. Can't seem to maneuver around here. (Karen: Emergency: 10
seconds of oxygen remaining.) I'm on it, Karen. I'm going. I'm
surfacing. Breaching- Oh god. Where's the
end of the ship? Oh god. Eugh. Oh fuck! Oh
noooooo!                    *SILENCE*                                     (sayonara   mark)
Heheh hahahaha! Hehehahaha! (x2) Aha! I survived! I don't
know how that did. How many people were
holding their OWN breaths expecting me
to drown again? That ain't gonna happen,
because I am super, super smart (sure, Mark).
Oh, did this run out of batteries? Really? *confusion*
Already? Well, that's no good.
Alrighty then.
Eee... Oh- Okay, I don't know where the fuck I am, and
I don't- The fuck is that? What is
that? *freaking out* What am I looking at?!
No, not- I mean not what am I looking at
what am I hearing. Both. Why- why is there new
music here? Okay...
Whoa. what was that? I don't know. Okay. What the
fuck? Why did I have to come here tonight?
Aaaalrighty then (Karen: Caution, 30 seconds of oxygen remaining) I need
that, I need that, I need that. Okay, going up!
Jeezums... It said something about
extending the debris field? And I'm
guessing this is- this must be, like, all
the new- like, Uh- Jesus (Karen: Emergency: 10 seconds of oxygen remaining.) there it is. This must be like
all the new uh- the new uh- new debris, I guess.
But I think- I still think I'm around the
engines, 'cause geez...
Oh, I don't like this.
Hello. I don't like the new music going on
there...
Am I STILL over the engines? Oh my god, I
am! Holy shit, this thing is wide as shit!
i do not remember this shit- the ship- the
shit ship being this wide. Like a- holy
crap...
Oh my god. That is nuts!
Okay we only just now cleared the back
end of the ship, and it's only just now
becoming day which is awfully convenient!
Thanks for doing that, by the way. *Sassiplier* Alright
so- Whoa, errr.. Okay, that's not very
comforting to know: that as soon as I
dive down this goddamn seadragon
Leviathan- What is that...? Oh, that's land!
And I thought- I thought that was the
outline of a goddamn fish! Ooo, that's not good...
You just stay down there in the deep,
I'll stay here in the shallows. We won't
talk to each other, or meet each other,
do anything to each other ever!
Alright, well, that was a terrifying
adventure that I didn't want to go on-
that I absolutely did not intend to go
to and around- and where the fuck am I? that's
a weird landmass that I've never seen
before...
Oh hey. Okay, too threatening. Okay, so what's
weird is what- why I'm so freaked out by
this is this is all completely new to me.
Like, this obviously has not been here.
None of this is accounted for. I have no
idea where I'm going, and we're starting
to really get into the new territory
here because all this land mass was not
here before. That is a hundred percent
definite, and I definitely don't even
remember seeing the Aurora on this kind
of scale here.
Hello- *chuckles* Hello bird... things... Whatever flying
creatures you are... I'm pretty sure this
is just an outcropping that the Aurora is
stuck onto, but I just need to- I just
need to explore to be able to see if
there's anything important here, because
otherwise I do believe it's just some
sort of... thing.
Um... Yeah, I'm not seeing anything on the horizon,
so maybe something over there?
Why is it SO rumbley? Is the Aurora just constantly
sinking more and more? That doesn't seem good. I'm just gonna get
this quartz while I can. I don't think
there's any other place that I can go to
up there, so I'm just gonna have to go on my
own down here. Shwhoop! Okay. And hopefully avoid
some deathly encounters... Oh boy. I probably
should have gotten some more food with
me because I might have a bit of an
issue once it comes to that.
Does it looks like iIke I'm about to make a lap of the
entire Aurora, because I'm getting towards
the front here and I don't know if
there's anything in the drop-off.
I don't have my seamoth, which is what I
REALLY need to be able to explore more
of this area, but I don't have it yet.
I am getting to the front of the Aurora
though so I'm just gonna- You know, I just
kinda want to make an accounting of
the the full area - Oh, God, that's a
drop-off. Ugh ugh
I HATE BEING NAKED IN THE OCEAN! Ehbubububa
Okay, well, that looks a lot more
magnanimous than it did before...
I'm not fooling myself. Is that bigger?
Is that bigger than it was or am I just
seeing it from a different perspective
than I have in the past? Because that
looks god damn huge!
I mean the Aurora is so unbelievably big
like the Aurora is just fuck duckin'
huge. How many people died on this ship?
How many people died, not only in the
initial explosion- oh fuck- but
afterwards? Just how many? There had to be
tens of thousands of people on a ship
this size. I believe this was a colony
ship intended to colonize a planet, have
everything that it needed to start a
completely independently functioning
colony.
And I think I may have found something
here... I dunno, it just looked-looked colorful (REALLY Mark *__* JK we love you)
so I was assuming maybe there's some
technology- Ah, man, that's gotta be bigger.
This has gotta be bigger. This is so huge.
It's so huge. (That's what she said.)
Ugh. Oh my God...
Uhhhhh, but even if it is, it doesn't matter,
because I'm gonna go inside it next. Is there a
way in through there?
Maybe, maybe not? Seems to be a way up. I'm
just gonna test it out because I don't
know. No harm in looking. No harm in looking
from this end. Ah. If anything I can just
go on the ship backwards from this added
from this area hopefully try to- "Ship
structural integrity is low, exploration
not advised." Well too bad I'm gonna explore
anyway. Batteries okay- oh boy.
Filtered water, good need to- whoa hey. Watch
out buddies
I got a knife and I'm not afraid to use
it. God damn. Ohhh this is flipping nuts! (flips a nut)
Okay, in we go. Oh my god, there's so many
things.
Thank you, I guess? Whoa, so many power
cells. Can I get some like- can I get some
like, food? (wanna burger?)
I might- might run low on food before- Ow, fuck!
Ahh! Fuuucking hell. Was that fire? Shit- Oh, it's just
falling debris, but jeez. Okay, I need to
take a first aid kit and get some water
in me. I've got oodles and oodles and
skadoodles of power cells, which is
really quite useful- Whoa. That was close.
Ahahhah I-I I'm I'm falling I'm falling I'm (What is with your arms?)
falling! We're falling! Okay, here we go.
Um, so I couldn't make my way back in it.
Seemed to be a dead end, anyway, so I'm
gonna try to find the other way in that
I normally know about and, hopefully,
that's going to mean that i can get some
more supply crates on the way. But the good
news is, if there is good news to take
out of this- what is this- if there is good
news-
oh what is this? Woo! Hey, that's handy!
Oh- Okay, cool! Oh, geez...
The Cyclops pieces! They're over here!
Neato burrito! Oh neato. I'm on it, I'm on it,
Karen, thank you...
Haaabooski! Okay, so if i get my bearings
right, my base should be over here. The
biomass in- Ooooh aaah aaah AHHH IT'S ON ME!
HE'S GONNA KILL ME! OH GOD!
RAWR!
BWAAAAAH!
AHHHH NO!!
Eh! Eh! It'll never get me in here!
Ohhhh god! Ohhhh god! Oh god, don't get stuck! (nearly got stuck)
Did it stop...?
Did it stop? Was it never after me in the
first place? *sigh* What's that glowy bit? There was
something the- the- that Karen was trying
to tell me in text, but I didn't see it
because I was screaming. *chuckling* I was a little
busy running for my goddamn life.
It said something about pieces of the
Aurora and something about the plants or-
are dominant in this area. I'm not a
hundred percent sure. I dunno.
At least I got power cells ^__^
for days, and extra batteries to go with
it, so i should be good on power cells
for like the rest of my life, even though
I didn't get a chance to scan anymore
for the Cyclops, but that's not really
why I'm here. Hehe (x2) Geez, that was not fun. ;[
It seems like the hole-in-the-wall
entrance that they had previously might
not be here anymore not a hundred percent sure
about that
okay I'm gonna puuut take these
out there you're going to be the power
uh jokes for days is going to be power 4
days so I'm just going to put the used
batteries in there and keep the unused
ones
alright see let's doot doot and doot
okay so we got now a total of eight trees
getting ready which should provide me
more than enough food when I come in
here this food won't stay if I want food
to take on the road I either need to
find rations or figure out a way to make
rations if there's an available recipe
on the ship but I don't know if that's
gonna happen so okay so my next step is
I just got to find a way into the Aurora
and I'm not going to waste your time i'm
just gonna go for it and when I come
back hopefully I'll have found my way in
I just have a funny feeling it might have been
on the other side and I was in such a
panic that I
did not see it because it's very
obviously not in the same place that it
once was- like maybe maybe if i use my
first aid or fire extinguisher here
I mean hey that works that weirdly
enough that works
oh shit
that's weird it actually putting out
these fires oh
hello
ooh
[Karen: caution, calorie deficiency detected]
ooh yay
oh cool yes I knew there had to be a way
oh that's so cool
it was like a sort of hidden walkway I
mean hidden I can't see shit but i found
it eventually I knew there had to be
something here
oh cool and they give you first aid kits
just in case you needed it because I got
burned by fire *gasps*
this is where i needed the- oh and there's
an extra fire extinguish here
oh cool oh was there anything else here- ooh so cool
oh it's so cool oh i love that ok there's
nothing else here
alright so now I knew there had to be
another way in that's so cool and
I'm gonna take this first aid kit just
because you know i may get hurt in there
who knows honestly; haf-woosh
alright so I got that but hang on i'm
out on this one drop that one put that
one
whoopsies one fwoooosh
alright firefighter markiplier coming in
hafwoosh
ok that way to the airlocks well all of
the airlocks have exploded into space
so that's not- *gasp* nice we're actually in a
ship ship
oh my god well hello whoa cool is what I
needed
ok systems are running on local reserve
pattern
I need to find another piece of that
that's the propulsion cannon which
should be
oh I get it ok so there's- ok so I-I heard
about this that you needed the
propulsion cannon to be able to move through
here and now it's making sense because
there are physical obstacles blocking my
way and i'm willing to bet that I can't just
jump over them can I? Can I use my sweet
hopping skills
nope maybe a little bit of hippity-hop
over here
nope all right so I'm gonna play that the
right way out and Imma find the other piece
of the propulsion cannon and then I'm
gonna be able to move those but I should
I should be able to go over here and
hopefully something else that I can get
that I might need is where i would need
a fire extinguisherrrrr please stop burning
Ow I said stop please tell me there's some
food in here just a little bit of
leftover food would be nice
alright PRAWN suit nice pickup PRAWN suit
poster
why do I need that can I put that in my
base to make it feel a little more like
home
that'd be nice- uh what is this heh I can scan I
could put a trash can in my place
oh that's lovely unless there's
something in this trash can that
absolutely need maybe trash cans nope
just got a blueprint for trash cans
new blueprint ackquired ok
Alterra launches the Aurora new
encyclopedia stuff okay but I haven't
found the other piece of the propulsion cannon
wonder where that went is there something here
that I'm missing is there anything here
that I'm missing
it's gotta be here i'm risking
starvation... I could probably find a way
to jump over these boxes though
I bet I could oh hello oh no this will
be easy herp
aw fu- well that didn't work alright hang on try that
again only got nine percent food left
which means starvation is imminent
if i go over here burn myself a bit
and just dropped out oh
NOOOOOOOO
[Karen: Welcome aboard captain] NOOOOOOOO
awwww
yay I made it okay good alright so I
got that I need to brush up real quick
and then we're going we're running out
of food were running out of oh God no
is that locked is that locked
I don't know the code was in- wait
was it in one of the logs that I got hang
on uh damaged pattern does not match any
known offensive technology that's
because it was all liquid and shit codes
yes yay ok uh 1454 ok bobbita ba- I'll read the
rest of that 1454 yay
open please give me food oh god
hello
hoooooly shit
what
what this is awesome
hello I'll take that you whoa whoa oh my
god I'm gonna starve to death but at
least I'm gonna have a lot of plans for
when i get back and resurrect in my own
base oh this is so cool
*gasp* YAAAAAAAAY a nutrient block
yes yes yeeees
oh my god oh that was so I'm saving now
oh that was so perfectly timed thank
you i should have scanned it fuck whoa
hey that's handy
alrighty then I got that now I've got a
third piece of everything in the
Cyclops well now that i have more time
to actually explore this thing i should
be able to take a closer look at every
oh this is so cool oh this is so cool can i
scan that ok I can't scan the nutrient
block I don't know why I thought I could
i don't know i thought i'd try
hey first time for everything why not
give it a gander
that's so cool oh this is awesome
yes more nutrient blocks yes please
look a bit I- that was a gamble that paid
off in dividends because my god
usually whenever I take a stupid bet
like that it never ever ever pans out
for me okay so nothing other up here I
gotta avoid all the droppy bits of fire
everywhere
ok so Geronimo I suppose
ok
yeah can I have you
thank you anything else in there
ow
you know the nutrient block
whoa- well this looks scary but why not
seamoth bay ooh I can get the seamoth
pattern
yes eugh this is weird ugh I wonder why there aren't more
dead bodies floating everywhere
unless they've already all been eaten by
the local fish life like that one
fuck you fuck that parasitic piece of
shit
yeah let's walk- ah fucking fuck can you
can you not
can you not can you can you can you not
thank you
shut up fuck you fuck you did I get you
I-I'm gonna getcha! Yeah fuck off.
Okay you know what, I'm just getting out
of here because fuck those things.
uhhhhhh Drive Room? I don't know if I need to go the
Drive Room. I was looking for the; "Drive core
shielding sustained moderate internal
damage during collision.
Do not attempt repair without
appropriate qualifications." Oh yeah this
is where I would stop all the radiation
leakage. Dammit I'm almost out of fire
juice. Okay but this is good because this
is where you would have come in if they
still had the other thing available
right now. Cyclops power efficiency
module? That's handy.
I do not have a repair tool yet, but this
is good to know. I wonder if there's
still like any sort of uh- scannable pieces
here. So once I get a repair tool, I will
come back to this, but I do not have time for
that now, jump over the fire, go to the
seamoth bay, find what I need. Find my
seamoth bay,
Oh no, Oh no. Ah shit I need a laser
cutter. Fuck. Where the fuck do I get
that? Damn it.
There's so many things here that I don't have.
Oh no!  I can't go to the seamoth bay
Oh no! I need the repair tool. Can I even
make that? I don't even know if I can
make that. Hang on. Let's get out of a
dangerous, infested area.
Aah! Fuck off ya piece of shit! Goddamn it I
guess I'll go back to the driveroom.
Ugh. Ok. Alright so do I know how to
make that is the big question. I can make
a repair tool and I can make a laser
cutter, so what I need to do is I need to
go make those things and then come back
here, but I know how to come back here so
that means that- Oh fucking stop with the
fire. Jesus. Okay. So that means that
when I get back here, unless there was a
way to get out here, but i don't think
there is.
Holy shit. Ok so when I come back here, I
will get the laser cutter and
the-the-uh-the not, the not so laser cutter.
Ok so I'm not seeing anything else here
just yet so I'm assuming I'm done for
now and I will come back when I have
everything that I need, which I don't
have right now, and I'm assuming that it
wanted me to find the propulsion cannon
before it was going to allow me to just
waltz on out of here, but. Hey, they should
have made it a bit more blocked up if
that's what they really wanted. So anyway,
I'm all out of time for this episode, but I
got a lot on my list to do for the next *Outro music fades in*
one. So, thank you everybody so much for
watching. Let me know what you thought
down the comments below and I might just
put you on a locker if you do, and thanks
again for watching. And as always I will
see you in the next video.
Buh Bye!!!
ouhaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaaa!!!!!
*Outro music*  ba ba ba ba ba ba!